pour la première fois
voilà maintenant quelques heures cet
après midi les parties devaient trouver
occupé en toupie et leurs préférences
politiques la veille d'un scrutin
essentiel pour leur destin avec une ex
rennes demain les particules entrent en
scène des milliers donc accompagné la
dépouille mortelle de nessus internet
qui s'inquiète pas des funérailles
nationales c'était le souhait de la
famille puisque les ministres portugais
noir avec plusieurs de ses
collaborateurs
mercredi soir à des funérailles
nationales mais une messe solennelle en
présence de nombreuses personnalités
étrangères est aussi plus longue
récession at il une procession et la
capitale portugaise devant des dizaines
et des dizaines de celle aucun portugal
en deuil qui mettra demain 7 millions
d'électeurs vont devoir désigner leurs
chaudes président de la république
particulière une élection qui apparaît
comme un aimant au capital de l'avenir
politique économique et sa salle du
tapis gall renaud albin et à lisbonne
ce km de nuit de prière de la tête
seront payés et rendre un dernier
hommage à sa carrière
la vie politique portugaise et est comme
suspendue à tout espace épicerie une
messe solennelle en présence du
gouvernement
de nombreux responsables politiques
étrangers arrivés ce matin pour
participer
mais tout se passait ce matin comme si
cette ferveur ne concernait qu'une
partie des portugais à quelques
kilomètres de là en plein centre c'était
après autres spectacles dont le décor la
toile de fond de l'élection
présidentielle semblaient laisser
indifférent lisbonne aujourd'hui ne
donnait pas l'impression d'être la
capitale d'un pays s'apprête à élire son
président de la république
les afficheurs sont certes toujours
présente elle rappelle que le portugal
choisi de main entre le président
sortant
le favori ramalho yanez qui souhaitent
continuer de conduire le pays sur le
chemin tracé depuis la révolution des
oeillets et le général soares carneiro
les candidats de la réforme
constitutionnelle le candidat de ceux
qui pensent à droite que la révolution
c'est aux côtés de sept hommes dont les
affiches électorales portes aujourd'hui
à crêpes à en signe de deuil
c'est le premier ministre disparu
s'était engagé personnellement et après
au cours de la dernière campagne
électorale
et beaucoup se pose aujourd'hui la
question de savoir si la disparition du
premier ministre ne va pas bouleverser
au moins partiellement les donner suite
à certaines électeurs ne vont pas avoir
un réflexe sentimentale qui pourrait les
amener à voter demain
gameiro avait fermement du côté des
partis communistes jusqu'en et amiens
scénographique et même d'extrême droite
je crois que frank c'est certainement
avec le recentrage qu'est ce qui se
passait mais je veux je dois vous dire
que les services soient plus service
date en train d'y présidence du candidat
de fraternelle son antique et la mort à
l'hôpital y en avoir les avantages pour
la vente chez lui dans le sens la
mobilisation de l'ailé s'était rendu
chez nous la manifestation aujourd'hui à
dublin
hier paris sur un seul et même thème
comment arracher à la mer les sept
militants républicains qui font la grève
de la faim depuis le 17 octobre dernier
dans leur prise en irlande du nord à
l'ubs lundi mille personnes sont
descendues dans la rue à paris ils
étaient quelques centaines à thème
commun sur les c'est quelque chose de
très noble cisjordanie en afghanistan
mais des responsables alors se vit comme
probablement dans l'ensemble de la
pologne la population ne semble pas
craindre au lendemain du sommet de
l'osce pour une entrée en force des
armes et se multiplient autres pays
faire ce qui inquiète le plus les
polonais c'est la crise économique très
sérieux
endettement extérieur énorme manque à
gagner considérable plus au chrtr
révélations sur l'inefficacité de
l'industrie lourde
on parle réformes économiques de modèle
pour oi
en attendant celles annoncées
rationnement sévère de la viande
depuis 1980 les images d'abondance
tourné en des temps meilleurs
nous sommes quatre ou cinq parmi les
raisons qu'on avance pour expliquer la
relative modération et andersen il ya
l'afghanistan ne savons pas mais voici
un témoignage qu'il met un super titre
par les rebelles eux-mêmes ils ont
réussi à battre un de leurs ennemis les
plus redoutés un hélicoptère ce site
existant ardent puisent leur inspiration
à deux sources
rennes de l'occupation étrangère est une
forme pure et dure
en cisjordanie c'était à prévoir
l'expulsion des mers palestiniens des
besoins de calcul vers le liban n'a fait
qu'exacerber les patients l'armée
israélienne a dû employer les gaz
lacrymogènes pour disperser des
manifestations un peu partout à mal à
dire est chrétienne s'est comme
d'habitude maintenant l'université de
birzeit qui s'agitent le plus les
militaires israéliens ont pris d'assaut
les dortoirs il récusait première de
l'université les étudiants c'est un jour
la terre trembler dans le sud de
l'italie
aujourd'hui deux semaines de café j'ai
cherché quelque 125 m2 et de couvertures
et de nani après l état des couvertures
qui soulève tout de même la misère cette
région du sud de l'italie
le comble du confort aujourd'hui c'est
un repas chaud et un véhicule pour
s'arrêter pour deux voitures dans les
cas un autobus dans le meilleur même
s'il faut que cela plaît prêt
conventionné
treize jours après le séisme les
fenêtres le sésime 9 de porto rial mme
quartiers pauvres de naples ces fenêtres
sont toujours fermés la ville a
relativement peu souffert
un seul immeuble s'est effondré mais dix
mille maisons ont été endommagées et
s'est maintenue personnes se sont
retrouvées sans abri
certains ont été relogés dans les hôtels
et jaune les plus pauvres s'est fait
dépouiller
ils ont pris d'assaut les autobus de la
ville le soir du tremblement de terre
nous sommes tous descendus dans la rue
nous étions choqués nous ne savions pas
où passer la nuit
nous sommes pro famille ici dans ce but
sont nos maisons sont les armes et nous
ne voulons pas rentrer regardez voilà
notre situation
qu'est ce que vous voulez contrat ils se
sont adaptés avec plus ou moins
d'imagination à 50 moins improvisées ils
n'ont ni chauffage ni eau
la nourriture un repas froid distribués
une fois par few il pense à tous ceux
qui sont restés sous les ruines de
l'immeuble d'à côté 52 personnes au
survivant à tout ce qui faisait leur
univers je ne sais pas ce que nous
allons devenir la municipalité ne
s'occupe pas de nous on nous promet
beaucoup de choses mais rien ne vient
les ingénieurs sont venus voir nos
immeubles mais aucun ne veut se
prononcer pour savoir si nous pourrons y
revenir
cette petite fille de 10 ans avec un
vocabulaire l'adulent ils nous
considèrent comme des bêtes
combien de temps reste-t-il ainsi
la municipalité a bien roulé chez
quelques uns de ses cent ans après le
tremblement de terre à découper des
problèmes chroniques de cette métropole
et sans abri sont de plus en plus
nombreux les déclarations ne suffisent
plus à les rassurer et leur colère
risque de se transformer en explosion
sociale de mille milliards de livres
soit 2 5 milliards sera nécessaire cette
année là l'histoire d'un testeur notant
que dans un train venu vers nous à côté
de nous retourner d'ailleurs une qualité
des nappes la veille par cinquante mille
réfugiés
c'est les championnats aussi consacré à
la lutte contre le terrorisme nucléaire
les américains et par un groupe le nesc
qui est déjà intervenu mais j'ai retenu
contre les actes de chantage à la mène
intermittence a toujours détesté le
temps là les soirs terre à terre face
aux autres compagnies aériennes
étrangères s'est pressée samedi à 20h30
les stones les hommes politiques de
déclarations seulement aujourd'hui celle
des messieurs personnel qui a exprimé
que le cepd marque actuelle se
caractérise et surtout par le grignotage
minutieux et libertés notamment chez
didier bariani qu'il préside aux
destinées du pays radicaux favorable à
la majorité
il a écrit à monsieur edgar faure et ses
aides sociales mais monsieur bargani
aussi que les chaussures de gainey a dit
j'ai ramassé la pâte et nikon de la
nature la différencier et composantes
qui en forme et le sacre il faut lancer
régulière c'est dur à dire lui faire
retrouver sa vocation
qui était ce une association de partis
qui ont chacun leurs spécificités et
chacun la programmation en commun de
soutenir le chef de l'état il faut que
cette association sur la corse et les
grandes lignes de force de son action ne
soit pas étroitement lié à l'action du
gouvernement et deviennent ainsi comment
la condamnée et a dû tenir le parti du
jour de l'action des pouvoirs pour quel
sera le rôle puisqu'il suffit du parti
radical au sein du dr pascal n'est pas
derrière le chef de l'état est parti
radical et 12 ans le parti radical nous
n'ont pas le même septennat avec même
zone l'accès il comprend jusqu'à la fin
étant le meilleur candidat il bénéficie
de nouveau la confiance du peuple
français mais une autre majorité avec
votre gare pour un autre contrat
j'ai des regrets c'est l'ancien
président de l'assemblée nationale
les malades hospitalisés à necker
docteur cette nuit un incendie s'est
déclaré hier soir les sous sols un
détail de cet hôpital incendie dont on
ne sait pas si les criminels ou non le
flat qui souhaitait les mains un 2-1 les
parisiens d'urologie n'est pas très
gentil mais quelqu'un a coûté le plan
d'urgence laisser sceptique considérable
de nettoyer l 58 malades évacués chemin
que les archives de l'hôpital necker
dans le plus souffert les années
quatre-vingt mille dossiers
il s'agirait d'un sénat de tous les deux
autres n'étaient pas encore présents
dans les services qui relie gignac n est
pas avant quelques jours
voilà ça des pensionnaires convenable
laquelle appellent également le temps de
la réflexion elle ne reprendra pas en
arrière le jazz projet n'est pas le
faire
c'est l'accusation et la défense ce
dernier en effet la n a qu à peine à
atteindre par les accusés j'ai parlé ce
matin vers une consommation de leurs
actions à la grenade ou d'attestation
deux jours dans quatre cas ni de france
était quand même salamine 101 peine deux
malfaiteurs ont été soit également que
le procédé le nombre des actes
c'est sans doute là le résultat de
l'arrestation d'un jeune homme que les
prix du conatel nation et qu'ils étaient
d'accord sur des premiers pour être
polis mais c'est un moment tenté de
l'étrangler liquides tels rien de grave
dans tout l'appareil que le trust les
côtes net n'est pas isolé mais qui est
en place dans une franchise volonté il
est fou des deux gendarmes de l'insee
n'est pas d'amener un peu d'air frais
dans leur île encore une commande vers
lui c'est le connaître les séries lost
et une fille de six appareils 5
prochaine depuis le connais valdir bus
96 appareils ont été vendus un karatéka
messieurs et une nouvelle politique a
bien sûr mais qui n'ont pas tous les
mêmes économique que connaissent mieux
retient ainsi la notaire que notre pays
la france au même espace une forte
inflation chômage aussi de sérieux
problèmes psychologiques
ces ouvriers de nottingham ont de la
chance ils ont un emploi un salaire
moyen d'environ 80 livres par semaine un
peu plus de 1500 pour les ouvriers
qualifiés et il échappe ainsi au chômage
qui touche tous deux millions d'hommes
et de femmes en grande bretagne très
souvent les plus compétitives les
entreprises britanniques font l'objet de
vifs reproches y compris de la part du
gouvernement de madame thatcher qui a
demandé le patron d'investir de renoncer
aux placements à court terme de remettre
de l'ordre chez eux
mais ceci envoie la vie notre problème
c'est que le gouvernement emprunte pro
donc l'argent de projets et la livre
sterling décroche donc la rentabilité
mais les exportations britanniques
seraient le trophée notamment résultats
de l'argent pour investir que le
gouvernement montre les dents après tout
il est lui-même un plâtre et s'il savait
se montrer aussi réaliste que le reste
de l'industrie en matière de dépenses et
notre situation serait pis m
de moderniser ses cuisines construite il
ya un peu plus de ta foi deux ans il en
a coûté environ 15 millions de livres
soit un peu plus de 150000 en mai la
production de bicyclette est un secteur
du buisson
le rapport à l'économie de la côte et
d'une politique économique visant à
réduire l'inflation
on est pressé de 22% à 15% cette année
en angleterre il écrit tout une action
plus écologique amener beaucoup
affirment que la vie industrielle est
mal organisé
les anglais doivent revoir leur emploi
du temps qu'il ya trop de poster de pau
syndicales qu'il faut remettre
l'angleterre au travail des propos qui
font sourire ici on les conteste il ne
faut rien conclure de quelques scènes
inédites
oui alors on commence à 7h du matin avec
10 minutes pendant la journée
en dehors des buteurs avec 20 minutes en
fin de journée laver les mains avant de
rentrer chez soi on ne peut pas dire que
chez nous il y en a qui partent le
moment anonymes
une exception est bel et bien être
mais je pourrais en citer bien d'autres
dans les entreprises il est vrai que les
négociations salariales appellons tour
se passe plutôt bien et syndicats
anglais renonce parfois de fortes
augmentations au maintien du pouvoir
d'achat
licencié salles anglaises inexportable
les revers de la médaille dans cette
mission pendant deux mois la semaine est
réduite à quatre jours les stocks sont
trop importants partout ailleurs le
patronat britannique espère de boules en
main en visant l'europe
seule issue c'est le même sac fermé
notamment des solutions au problème de
l'emploi
les accords des secteurs et qu'elle a
suivie par exemple que les collecteurs
de la scène est content c'est la réalité
et la lavande dans l'univers france ne
soit pas seulement
enfin la réalité des choix parfois
critiquée par les initiales ce champ de
lavande de la banda de la lavande
c'est un peu une image carte postale la
réalité est quand même tout autre un peu
moins belle la crise que connaît
l'agriculture depuis quatre ans va en
s'amplifiant
alors vous qui êtes un petit exploitant
comment ressentez-vous s'exprime après
le catastrophe parce que quatre à
l'avant de la banda ne sont pas
considérés comme des produits agricoles
mais industriels
de ce fait ils ne bénéficient pas déçu
d'un joli marché commun par contre les
lavandiculteurs son gaz exploitants
agricoles et la veille de la conférence
annuelle agricole une cinquantaine
d'entre eux entreprenait dernière
compagne pacifique de sensibilisation
pour faire connaître il ya quatre ans
j'avais déjà les premières ce n'est ce
pas si la production était stable elle
était donc heureusement concurrencé par
les importations massives et rss au
début le carry est menacée dans les
essences de synthèse 22 novembre la
coupe était pleine
un attentat était le fruit d'un autre
taux de soldes à la plantation massive
et mal contrôlée des chances de mauvaise
qualité d'importation notre encore à la
miss aurait refait de la bande à
deschamps de l'avant notre appétit bien
sûr via la coopérative 2 mondial est un
déficit de plusieurs millions de francs
suite à la dégradation des poudres sur
le marché national il ya actuellement 70
tonnes d'essence de lavandin vendu 15
sont tous les sens de la vendent les
produits d'importation et de synthèse
continue d'innover le marché bénéficiant
d'une absence de strictes règles
notation
il ne faut pas passer nous n'avons pas
cette orientation le moment venu nous
ferons connaître aux consommateurs ce
qu'il ya dans les flacons et dès à
présent nous pouvons déjà dire que
lorsqu'il ya le mot 5h odeurs fraîcheur
et bien souvent fraîche que dans la
majorité des cas il n'y a pas le produit
c'était à l'intérieur et nous dirons
nous pouvons dire également que dans le
petit flacon qui coûte très cher et bien
la valeur du produit qui est à
l'intérieur on représente bien souvent à
peine la valeur de la marque que cela et
à supposer encore bijoux que ce produit
la chaux naturelle ce qui n'est pas
toujours forcément le cas mon héros
c'est la nature
et comme le disait un célèbre maître des
planes pas parce que son expérience se
repose sur des millénaires
c'est un emploi car la conférence
annuelle à l'école du 5 décembre à
adopter comme le jure plus nette de 50
millions d'euros
les petites productions de la
méditerranée sèche et l'oeuvre du
sculpteur en font partie mais outre une
aide financière
c'est une législation stricte qu'ils
demandent que des jeudis jusqu'à la lie
cela monaco l'une des capitales
européennes du jeu s'est transformée en
capitale mondiale du cirque pour la
cinquième année consécutive la passe
sautée analyse un festival international
des gens de la piste des plus égale à
celle que l'occasion se rencontrer pour
des spectacles
cinq ans il ya l'odeur d'essence avec
les coaches autonomie toute l'année
l'odeur de dollars dans les salles de
jeux du casino
mais en décembre tous les ans pendant
cinq jours mon info sans le faux secret
finale internationale du cirque
il attire les artistes du monde entier
qui plantent leur chapiteau sur le
nouveau port au milieu des effluves de
paille fraîche de crespin et de grands
espaces
c'est devenu le rendez vous traditionnel
les enfants de la numéro de cirque
l'enfant lui seul le spectacle il donne
le frisson à d'autres enfants et
spectacles festivals de noter qu'un
incident entre construite une une partie
10 ans
tous les problèmes ce qu'ils sont que
depuis des années on entend la même
litanie le circuit car c'est vrai
l'histoire du cir particulièrement en
france c'est aussi une longue suite de
faillites est de retour il en rappelez
vous les problèmes de pinder famille
nancy jean richard qui ne sont que
quelques exemples parmi d'autres
pourtant malgré les difficultés les
mêmes numéros les mêmes figures imposées
se retrouve au grand rendez vous cette
fois à monaco il ya 38 infractions
punies de plus de 15 pays avec sept
festivals maintenant organiser je pense
que vous avez une idée précise de ce qui
se passe dans le site alors on dit qu'il
ya une crise
à votre avis je crois qu'il ya quand
même une crise et qui sont illuminés
moins grave enfin la crise existe et
alors qu'est ce que c'est une fille de
spectateurs une crise d artistes une
crise de moyens financiers je pense que
c'est un ensemble de plus chaque
spectateur mais parce que souvent les
stocks ne sont pas très bons
les numéros qui chantent enfin de
nourrir les clowns
on a beaucoup de mal à trouver nulle
voilà nous sommes très très bon le clown
se meurt écrasé par les charges fiscales
le prix du carburant est aussi par la
concurrence de la télévision et le
cinéma
de tout temps la gestuelle syrte à
ressembler à l'arbre final
partout se faire apprécier et c'est le
rôle d'un festival comme celui de karl
une distinction récolté à monaco ce sont
des engagements assuré pour plusieurs le
nom des états unis doit ce festival
parce que c'est une bonne l'année
secteur oui c'est important c'est un
aboutissement dans une carrière c'est un
honneur sera gagnant c'est une très
bonne chose que mon travail
beaucoup de gens bénéficient des
directeurs des sites des producteurs les
imprésarios
sopra sans doute toujours les 600
rassure vive la police ce ne sont pas
les plus grands chapiteaux ce sont des
trous volume et plus encore
chacune à distance hier après la levée
du bastia 3-0 de match avait lieu
l'après midi ainsi que sochaux a battu
nîmes 2 ap 1 et metz a battu merci de
lui alors si je peux matchs ont lieu ce
soir la dernière heure de l'est et il
importe la séquence novatrices
keystone affronter l'italie en finale le
double décisif allait lui et ses
acolytes il ya deux justices cabinet
themis journal
une fois qu'on peut lire danger déjà que
la coupe telus le 3 août pour la
première fois en effet en 80 ans
d'existence un pays de l'est remporté la
coupe davis après saint denis américaine
mastrad deux victoires en simple aux
dépens panatta est l'un des attraits
barazzutti est ici une performance en
double il ya trente mille la
confirmation d'un deuxième joueur au
monde en simple excellent partenaire de
boue vainqueur en demi finale de
l'australie l'argentine elle même
qualité
dernier survivant du dvd pas quand nous
est passé en or il ya 86 les délices
étudiant à harvard lance l'idée d'une
compétition internationale par équipe
pour développer le tennis c'est lui un
pionnier le docteur douanes s'est fondé
à munich et costain l'horrible s'allier
dida féminin continent la coupe davis a
perdu sur la fac était l'an prochain la
nouvelle formule consiste à rassembler
16 équipes comme dans un tome anormale
et une amende simple dimanche il ira
chercher demain cela se passera a opté
dans le prix georges courtois il s'agit
d'un article 13 qui se court sur 4400
mètres c'est la neige sur la nana ce
n'est pas qu'il a un certain nombre qui
l'arrêteront échiquier le 2 dans leur
soap à nice le 7 tricycle local famille
no 8
hippisme qu'est ce qui peut les frais
légaux ring le 4 au premier pronostic de
pierre matière
les skieurs pour quelques chanceux
aujourd'hui les mains des syndics qui
fait participer des 5 de la saison
analyse erronée c'est la sq à l'hôtel et
ce pour le deuxième jour consécutif
la neige qui tombe
extrêmement violent sur le haut de la
piste
est ce qu'il ya derrière attention il ya
danger d'avalanches en montagne et selon
le centre les filles de la neige de
grenoble ces risques sont extrêmement
sérieux notamment pour tous ceux qui
sont décédés
puisqu'ils artistes un conseil donc
soyez extrêmement prudents le week-end
aujourd'hui la météo les températures
étaient légèrement supérieures à la nage
spécifique fait à nice et à perpignan le
fera pourtant revient sont appropriés
des mails général les germes l'intérieur
du pays sont variables et de passages
nuageux
le mistral et la tramontane soufflera
ailleurs les honneurs faiblir résultat
les intérêts